- So this thing is about Tom
Felton and Emily Rodakowski
playing secret service agents?
Yeah right, and I've never
been to a whore house
in Thailand.
- What's up homies,
how we doing?
Oh I'm sorry.
What's up Kevin, are
you feeling well?
- Do they turn you out of
some kind of Seacrest factory
because you're in my star
path and you've been on
my dick for years.
What's your beef?
- Listen Centrum Silver,
I want your show.
Okay, and you're
in the way of that
and everyone knows you're
a fuck up so step aside
and let me take it all right?
- If I hadn't had hemorrhoid
surgery a week ago
I would kick your
ass right here.
- Hi, so we're going to
head up to the 15th floor.
We're going to get
started soon okay?
So you three please
come with me.
- It's like Celebrity
Death Match but without
the celebrity part.
(upbeat music)
- You are such a little shit.
I've heard enough.
I think you're just
born a douche bag.
- You're so dumb.
- Tom, that's movie's terrific.
No seriously, you are.
- You never stop.
- Do you get that in
your mother's milk.
- You never stop.
- [Voiceover] What up guys?
- [Voiceover] Oh my
god look, fudge tray.
- [Voiceover] Are you for real?
- Dude.
- I'm available.
- Great.
I will just get on this
supermodel's elevator.
- I'm Emily.
- Hey Deckard.
- Oh my god, from Movie Leagues?
- Yeah.
- Wow, I loved your piece
on the DC multi-verse.
- Did Kevin put you up to this?
- I don't know who Kevin
is, but can I just say
like can we please all
agree what Cannon is?
Don't throw away what Grant
Guston is doing on CW.
- Oh my god right?
- [Emily] Yeah.
- Why don't you give him
a little room jerk face?
- Jerk face?
- Yeah.
- What was that like the hot
insult of 1993 or something?
- You know Tom, I
want to apologize.
This is unprofessional.
I don't mean to involve you
in what we're doing here.
- It's fine, it's fine really.
- No, no, no look, you
don't have to bring yourself
into it, seriously.
It's between us.
- That's weird.
- [Voiceover] Ladies and
gentlemen, our elevator power
is temporarily shut down.
Please remain calm, sorry
for the inconvenience.
- Oh, oh, are you, are you okay?
- You would make an
amazing Wonder Woman.
- Okay you know when
they say remain calm,
that means that they can't
do anything about this
right now.
We are all going to die in here.
- No, no, no, we
are not going to die
because I just got
verified on Twitter
and it is really
hard to do that.
All right, now is not the time.
- Would you just calm down?
- I knew I was going to
die with somebody famous.
Take me Lord.
- [Tom] What is he doing?
No one's going to die dude.
- There's a hooker's panties
in my glove compartment.
- Is he, is he crying?
- (crying) There's so
many regrets I have.
I should have punched
you so much earlier.
- So wait, like you've
written 23 books
and you haven't
published any of them?
Well I'm almost
done with number 24.
- I would love to read that.
- You would?
- Yeah, I'd love to
get inside that brain.
- Okay.
- You guys need to
sort your shit out,
okay, this isn't,
it's not professional,
it's not healthy.
Try this.
We used to actually do
this on Potter when me
and Maggie Smith would clash.
You're going to look deep
into each other's eyes
and say the very first thing
that comes to your mind.
- Crypt keeper.
- Job stealer.
- Did you call my crypt keeper?
- Yes.
- That, that, that's no, that
was like four words each.
It was supposed to be.
- He did too many
words, I did one.
- Well I...
- I did one word, so
I followed the rules.
Let's try something else.
- This is taking a while, yeah?
- Wait, we're not in
the elevator right now?
- No.
- Honestly this whole
time I thought we were
in the elevator.
- Yeah, no, no, we're
definitely not in an elevator
right now.
- We haven't gone anywhere?
- No, we're definitely
in the lobby.
- What floor are we on?
- In a lobby.
- Shake it, get that energy out.
- You don't exist because
you're not on social media.
- Hummmmm.
- Kevin you're really
kind of my role model.
- You're a cat, you're a cat.
- Christopher, I feel
like you're my son.
Am I cat too?
- No, you're a unicorn.
- Woo, running.
- Let's hug it out.
- No, no, with
Christopher, Christopher.
- [Kevin] (crying) You're
like a son to me, like a son.
- Do you ever feel like
these kind of things happen
for a reason?
- Like when Kylo Ren murdered
his father Hans Solo.
- Spoiler alert, but yes.
- I do.
(sighing)
- Oh.
- Oh hey, guys this is Emily.
We were just trapped
in the elevator
and it was magical and...
- I was just trying to be nice.
- Oh sorry.
- Call me.
(dinging)
- Hey thank Tom,
thanks, thanks a lot.
- Tom, thank you very much.
- All right guys.
- Yeah, I just wanted to
be clear on something.
If anyone catches wind
of this I'm just going
to deny it.
- Deny what?
- Exactly.
- All right, cool.
(rock music)